hello everyone and welcome to the
tiebreaks of the 2019 FIBA World Cup
tomorrow job of vs. ding leerin it's
quite quite a messy game but we were
expecting Messi games when we get past
the classical time format and well
everything stays the same they are
battling it out for the first place for
the 110 thousand dollars that's
basically all there is to it as they
have both both already qualified for the
2020 candidates tournament so that being
said let's just dive straight into it
without further ado so rajababu the
white pieces opens with a knife to f3
the reti opening is on the board with d5
biding d4 Knight f6 with c4 and a six
and with Knight to c3 we transpose into
the Queen's Gambit a client of course
and c5 the cemetery with C chapters on
d5 better job of Knight captures and III
and C capture Sundy for trading
everything in the centre
he captures on d4 and now even Knight
captures on c3 be captures and c3
improving white center and Queen to c7
are developing the Queen or again with
with a threat with Bishop d2 biding
somewhat of our passive move with the
bishop but you know it's if it works why
not you're going to play rook c1 at some
point you're gonna pull it up onto c4
and the bishop will come alive with
nights the d7 by ding and now Bishop to
d3 just developing preparing to Castle
kingside b6 things ready not feeling
care to the light square bishop this way
and Knight to g5 just a very nice piece
creating some threats on the Kings side
white well black will not be all that
eager to castle there and well maybe you
can get some h6 here so you can weaken
adding skin-side Knight to f6 biding now
defending the h7 point twice and the
Queen to f3 developing the Queen going
after the rook on e on a 8 look to be a
biding defending and now castles by her
job of and here
Bishop to d6 putting pressure on our
jobs h2 pawn queen to h3 defending now
you still cannot castle as there's a
triple attack on the h7 pawn so h6 and
here are a job of after thinking about
the position for quite some time goes
Knight to f3 and already the time of the
clock is much different reserve both has
12 minutes on the clock whereas ding has
26 minutes on the clock there is a
seemingly aggressive rook F to e 1
because you the knight cannot be
captured there's no point in moving it
right away but then you allow Bishop
captures on h2 and then after Queen
captures Queen captures now the knight
can be captured with check and have to
remove the King g4 and well if it was a
classical game white would be perhaps
somewhat better due to the bishop repair
but here in a rapid game not something
you want to force with black so a wood
white so Knight back to f3 pirate above
and now there is one game in the
database where bush of the f4 was played
seems like like a reasonable idea as you
don't want to kind of ah
c4 and this Bishop may be getting to be
four but dingos Bishop to b7 first and
it is as of move 15 that we have a
completely new game so rook F 2 e1 now
with some ideas of maybe at some point
sacrificing the rook here then the
bishop can come to g6 the Queen can come
to e6 ding first captures the knight and
gives up the bishop pair with Bishop
captures Queen captures as this allows
him to grab a pond and the Bishop
captures an h2 with check a job who
doesn't mind giving up a pawn King to f1
and now Bishop back to d6 and here Queen
again back to h3 again with some with
some nasty ideas here as the king is
still in the center of the board and
here well as Queen h3 was not played yet
I I switched the move order actually c4
was played here before that
now if Bishop to f4 was ever going to be
played now this Bishop can assume this
nice diagonal this was a reserves idea
and only after dings h5 move and now you
can't castle here that's the point if
you castle here then you get any run
into Bishop captures captures and Queen
captures here just destroying leadings
King side so here ding tries h5 he wants
to play King to f8 and maybe at some
point play g6 King g7 and get the rook
into
somehow this way and now Quint h3 the
movie I thought was played in the
previous move but now again a lot of
threats against the Lynx king as it's
still in the center of the board and
only now they move the King to f8 so now
the king is much safer there and you are
planning g6 maybe at some point get your
king into into a safer Square
we've looked the b1 now a reserve of
Spanish he he wants to make a very nice
rope lift here with rook the b-52 g5 and
get the rook into the attack as well so
you have to you have to decide what to
do if you if you go into g6 with King to
g7 right away then it's you always have
to ask yourself can white play something
like Bishop captures captures and rook
captures on e6 but it would be it would
be it wouldn't be good for white right
away but you you have to constantly keep
an eye on you can play king f7 this now
becomes a threat Queen captures here
with just picking up the rook so a lot
of dangerous here yeah but okay ding
just plays the solid rook to d8 and now
Bishop to c3 now the bishop is already
on a very nice diagonal some g6 ideas
followed by King g7 you can go d5 open
up the bishops diagonal very very tricky
14 but things the plus side is that he's
still very much up on the clock and he
goes rook to h6 getting the rock out of
this nasty diagonal and also now
preparing maybe some King side expansion
with the g5 h4n to g4 and here we have a
4 better job of he wants to play a 5 and
weakened dings dings Queen side maybe
even get c5 in at some point and here
the situation on the clock is 16 minutes
for a job of 16 minutes ding five
minutes for a job of and then goes h4
first not going for g5 right away you
could always go for g5 but it's a tricky
line for example if Luke b5 keeping an
eye on the g5 for now
nice the d5 is very strong as you will
not be able to capture it because of
Queen captures on c3 and also if this
Knight comes to f4 it will be very
unpleasant
so not g5 right away but first h4 now
with the idea
ding doesn't doesn't like Knight d5 with
a lot of calculation required he wants
to go night
h 5 - f 4 so the getting the night work
for this way and here we have king back
to G 1 just just an in-between not going
for rook to be 5 right away so ding
continues with his with his plan with
night going to H five the night now
wants to go to h4 and Bishop the f1 now
with more defense to the G to pawn with
Knight to f4 now the queen is under
attack Queen back to f3 and now rook the
f6 biding I just positioning the rook on
the same file as the Queen and also if
h3 right away then g3 is perfectly safe
for white algebra was able to calculate
that with a low time on the clock
if h2 checking each one and now let's
say a trade happens here that's nothing
to be worried about you're gonna push c5
and it's well there are a lot of threats
for white also in the position you can
go route captures on e6 and there are
other dangerous your Bishop captures in
g3 it does not work for black so after
Queen to f3 we have looked at f6 biding
like we said and now comes Queen to b4
by her job of getting the Queen out of
the way and here it was well it was a
very intense moment this situation is a
three minutes or job of ten minutes dink
and dingos back Knight to g6 although
there was the idea of going h3 right
away now g3 can be met with Knights to
h5 and the all sorts of threats become
possible like you could sacrifice the
bishop on g3 pick it up with the Queen
after capture then you could pick up the
bishop on c3 but still it's a rapid game
a double down on the clock you don't
want to over calculate it and allow the
job was to calculate as well so instead
nice the g6 and now we have looked to be
to just getting another defender to
defended the second-ranked and now comes
h3 so it's a similar but but not the
same like we said you cannot push g3 the
bishop will munch it up right away so G
captures on h3 and now rook the f4
biding pushing the reserves Queen back
Queen all the way to h1 and now Knight
to h4 and this is really a crazy crazy
position we have looked at e3
nice rook lift as now both defending the
bishop and also guarding the
third-ranked and the now comes rook back
to f5 opening up this diagonal for the
bishop and also the the rook is very
important there as it doesn't allow nice
to f3 check so look the b5 better job of
not allowing this rook to g5 check which
will which would be deadly and here ding
played a 5 he blocked the rooks defense
of the of the 5th ranked but there was
an even better move so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
move that being missed which is just a
game over for white while I give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
are able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent giver up of the bishop
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show Bishop to c5 and this is
now deadly the roof no longer defense g5
roof to g5 check will be deadly nd of
course if you captured the rock then
still just rogue g5 check Bishop hat
will block and then just rock the d1 as
the D file is now open you will block
and an outcome squint f4 and here white
is completely tied down you can do
pretty much whatever you want there's
not much you cannot block with the rook
rook captures anyone if you do nothing
just rope captures and g2 completely
winning for dink
but being played 'if I've instead it
serves the same purpose rook to g5 is
coming but here a job of managers to get
c5 in and now Dean has to decide what to
do now look the g5 is not the same
because here you can block with rook to
g3 and it's it's hard to decide what
what to do here there is a very
interesting line although impossible to
spot in a rapid game is efore and now
it's just all hell breaks loose on the
board for example if if rook captures
here then you have this Bishop to h2
check which is just insane Queen
captures and now Knight f3 check of
course you have to play something King
King G - let's say Queen captures on h2
is checkmate but it's not forced but
after E 4 it's just hard to find a move
for white in a rapid game but instead
then goes back to Bishop to e7 and now
quickly Queen to b4 freeing the h1
square for the King also a pressuring
the knight and the rook on f5 they're
all the
but still there is pressure we have
looked f-for pushing the Queen once
again back and here the situation is 10
seconds on the clock for her job of and
one minute 14c capture son v6 first
offering the Queen trade being
recaptures in the now queen h7
threatening mate in one night back to g6
regarding the h8 swear and now just
rugby captures on e5 doubling up here
and well it seems that ding is no longer
on the attack it seems our job is on the
attack now and he he also consolidated
very nicely
we've looked h4 biding sort of trapping
the Queen but not really as a job of can
defend rook to h5 with captures captures
and now Bishop to f6 and again here at
Rajah bow goes for Queen to b5 but there
is a much better move although with so
little time on the clock impossible to
spot but feel free to pause the video
and try to find this wonderful idea for
white well I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on being an
excellent pusher of passports or in this
case soon to be passed pawns and for
those of you who just won in your show
a5 is just just a game-changer here
because if you capture them just Bishop
captures wins the material here the
Queen and rook around the same diagonal
if you don't capture white will push a
sixth-grader passed pawn and that's
that's a winning pass pawn now but ok
like I said impossible to find with so
little time on the clock we have Queen
to b5 and now comes Knight to h4 we have
Bishop to b4 check King to g8 and now
rook to e8 check that's the idea behind
Queen to b5 rook captures Queen captures
with check and King to h7 sorry about
that
and here Queen efore again with check we
have g6 blocking and now comes d5 here
our job of is starting to push his a
past deep on ding plays Knight to f5 and
here seems like a job of a reserve rush
that he played d6 just giving up this
passed pawn with with the idea that he
can he can do something it's hard to say
what as he has very little time on the
clock
ding just
rabbit and he played Queen to f6 not
with a double attack here and here but
ding has nice ta defending the Queen
ended the bishop here
so the a queen trade occurred here we
have Queen captures night chapters and
now Bishop to c4 so it's equal material
on the board but play on both sides of
the board and there a job with the
bishop pair going after the f7 pawn so
King g7 with Bishop to d6 and now nice
th and here Bishop the b8 just nicely
controlling the night here preparing
Bishop to b5 to harass the night so
Bishop to d8 creating an escape square
for the night with Bishop to e5 with
check Bishop blocking ding wants to
trade now and here they're they're equal
in the clock I believe 30 seconds each
both playing on increment Bishop back to
be 8 and now Bishop back to DA biding
with the f4 or a job of does the one to
draw he still has the bishop pair Bishop
to c7 and now Bishop to e3 they are
putting pressure on the b6 bond with
Knights the d6 going after the Bishop
Bishop to d4 check f6 now and now comes
the Bishop to d3 with Knights the b7 the
Shabak the c2 in the now Knights to d8
just maneuvering around the Shabak the
e4 and now tonight the e6 with Bishop to
e3 and now f5 biding so slowly making
progress on the Kings side Bishop to c6
and King to f6 we have King to g2
and now g5 biding so moving forward with
the pawn from Bishop to d7 and now
things just played Knight to f4 check
and here our job would have to make a
choice does he want to continue does he
want to trade he decided at the trade
end after Bishop captures on f4 it was
in this position that the players agree
to a draw as it's three points each and
our bishops of opposite color it is it
is a drawn in game so really insane game
round around one of the tiebreaks of the
rapid tiebreaks I do hope you enjoyed it
really really crazy stuff so a game to
probably is just about to begin so I'm
about to check in check check that out
as well and if it's a nice one we're
gonna show that as well so I do hope you
enjoyed it chances on both sides about
Indian
a remarkable draw would equal material
on the board sir
I would like to thank Ferdinand Albin
and Linus Ryan and Charles shredder for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon
checking up on defeated World Cup
checking up on the on your suggestions
and so on so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day